[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
welcome to Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon the
franchise that pioneered the tactical
genre in 2001 Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon
defines the squad based military shooter
genre with realistic and challenging
games life
as a powerful sequel Ghost Recon 2
introduces a dynamic shift to
third-person and supports up to 16
players and enhanced multiplayer modes
Ghost Recon Advanced Warfighter improves
the focus on team coordination and
features actual military prototype
equipment and weapons
one year later Ghost Recon Advanced
Warfighter - delivers a deeply immersive
campaign and multiplayer future war
experience with the ability to command
supporting units
in 2012 Ghost Recon Future Soldier makes
a shift to exhilarating cover based
gameplay with the inclusion of the stink
shot gunsmith and adaptive camouflage
technology
and in 2017 Ghost Recon wildlands leads
a tactical shooter into a breathtaking
open world experience to explore either
solo or up to four player co-op as well
as an attack table for V for PvP mode in
ghost war
and now the future of Ghost Recon hey
everyone
my name is Emil Dallben I'm a u.s. army
green beret I've served with Special
Forces for 14 years and have deployed
all over the world I'm also very proud
to be a writer on a new Ghost Recon game
being part of the Ubisoft team has been
an incredible journey for me and we are
so excited to share with you our
community an experience that is going to
bring players closer to real Special
Operations missions than ever before
when we launched Ghost Recon violence we
read an action-packed open world
military shooter that can be played in
solo and a 4 player coop from beginning
to end we'll completely blown away by
your response we are so grateful to a
community that has brought more than 15
million players it's an honor the stakes
are high
today we're super excited to introduce a
brand new go shootin game to you so
let's get to it
our story begins on a remote island in
the middle of the Pacific Ocean
called Aurora the mythical golem was
imagined as an artificial intelligence
designed to serve and protect the myth
is now a reality
this self-driving vehicle crossed the
entire United States without a human
touching the wheel the computer was
creative it outsmarted me every step of
the way
entrepreneur visionary genius JCL is
planning to change the world
this is our first deployment of lethal
drones they have already saved countless
lives from our new headquarters on Naru
archipelago
skel technology will quite simply build
the future
skel type drones will enhance industries
across the globe they will eliminate
food shortages heal the sick and in time
erase poverty mr. Skell critics claimed
that with new autonomous systems we risk
summoning the devil what do you say to
that we combine AI machinery to serve
humanity peacefully
I am personally dedicated
scary machines that can act together
react faster than humans they're cheaper
more efficient than any other measure
there's no doubt the swarm surveillance
systems will reduce crime on our streets
with mr. Skell care to comment on the
recent assassination of a political
candidate by a lethal drone mr. Skell
has no comment at the time
lethal autonomous weapons are being
developed and deployed without oversight
or limitations they are the next global
threat the UN must vote to enact
sanctions on the spread of these weapons
we must act now we've lost contact with
a roller no way to reach a scale
yes sir I understand the risk level
we're sending them in
the rules are elites pickup soldiers the
best of the best the just how far can
you push the rules
how strong are they how much then detect
before the break the breakpoint is a
force posture change shift from tag to
defend from defend to withdraw recon to
survive it is the moment when a unit is
lost its combat effectiveness was no
longer able to find the onset of this
inability to carry out a mission
constitutes a breath boy this is Ghost
Recon break point in the past the ghost
had a plan what if this time there was
no briefing
what is this time the enemy expected
let's start at the beginning of course
recon break points your cosine is nomad
the ghost sent 200 odd you have been
sent there for what seems to be a usual
mission but this is far from what is
about to happen
from this point on all of your military
survival skills will be put to the test
as you make your way through this
mysterious island you will discover the
majesty the beauty and diversity of this
brand new open world from snowy peaks to
sandy beaches jungles deserts fjords
even a volcano but you're not on a Rohit
to sightsee nestled in a beautiful
archipelago and driven by the singular
vision of accomplished engineer JCL they
develop AI and autonomous drones scarce
mission is to make the world a better
place but the road to hell is paved with
good intentions in the wrong hands
aurora ku turn into the most dangerous
place on earth and it does you are no
longer the hunter you are the hunter and
even worse the hunters are unit of
elites pick up soldiers gone rogue he
had the same training as you same
experience and they could then say of
the wolves and they have taken over the
island the wolves are the most
formidable opponents the ghosts have
ever had to face not only have they
taken over a row they've also
reprogrammed skells drones to become
powerful killing machines
you lost behind enemy lines and your
enemy is powerful and nurses so ghosts
can you survive your breakpoint
dose 1 1 disgusting I'm - lights out
your location but a guy subpaths on my
ass value of me to eliminate this break
[Music]
[Music]
take cover I'll be good
nothing to report I'm gonna continue my
search
recoding for the patient you have lost
[Music]
[Music]
picked over Bravo Team will set a
diversion of the gate may 1 1 will it
fill the campus rare
I got right
[Music]
ronzo
they're no walls but they got numbers
Bravo Team I was in your position
three hostiles it's an alpha stroke
nothing here either nothing ever happens
around
I have the troll drones out
go sleep we're set
Rosie the hostiles inbound your location
why are they doing this
have you come
Rostow down
is on the go
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
everything you saw in this walkthrough
was made possible thanks to one thing
experienced seven years ago we started
wildlands with a team of 30 we now have
more than a thousand developers focused
on Ghost Recon in the past two years
alone we've released 19 title updates
breakpoint is bigger and better than
anything we've done before this new game
puts you in the boots of an elite
Special Operations soldier and on a
roller you'll need every bit of your
training and experience to survive the
terrain has a real impact on your
gameplay it can be your enemy oh you're
alive you'll have to cross bodies of
water and climate slopes will make you
slide and temple but you'll have the
agility and new skills with the prone
camo feature you can truly blend into
your environment using your surroundings
to escape or surprise your enemies and
to make the experience more immersive
and intense players can also suffer
serious injuries
depending on the gravity of the world
players will need to adapt and they
still gave their rifle can there were an
escape unfortunately you will also be
able to heal yourself either on the spot
or in the brand-new bivouac the bivouac
feature will allow players to rest and
refit in the wilderness with their squad
and do what real Special Operations
soldiers do you'll have a wide variety
of tools at your disposal be able to cut
through fences and love to drone that
will allow you to sync shot several
targets even in solo or use a rocket
launcher to take down enemies
but survival isn't only about fighting
it's also about stealth you can pick up
and hide the body of an enemy to remain
undetected or move your fellow wounded
ghosts to safety finally you'll be able
to play as multiple classes and will be
able to change class at any time from
the big work for different classes will
be available at lounge with more to come
the thinking behind many of these
gameplay mechanics came from you our
community let's hear about how Ghost
Recon breakpoint has been inspired by
your feedback you have been our secret
weapon in taking Ghost Recon to a whole
new level
first Ghost Recon breakpoint will
feature a new main story with hundreds
of cutscenes dialogue choices and more
characters for you to discover the
variety of enemies your face will keep
things interesting to say the least
there are many enemy archetypes with
different abilities and weapons and
they're dangerous like this armored
behemoth that will take strength and
precision to take down enemy behavior
has also evolved if you get spotted or
if they become suspicious your enemies
on our coordinate together to take you
want enemies will now always be on
patrol throughout the world a constant
reminder that in Ghost Recon break point
you're the prey and to take them on
you'll now have fan favorites and all
new weapons at your disposal the
gunsmith will give you access to a ton
of different attachments it'll have a
lot more impact on weapon statistics and
performance and you'll have even more
options for character customization and
yes this does include blouse boots
you'll be able to explore a rower on
road and off by air and by sea and
there'll be more military vehicles to
traverse this new world want to go fast
take a falcon wanna plow through the
jungle take a Fat Boy want to fight the
Wolves try a locust
of course Ghost Recon breakpoint is
fully playable in solo and up to four
player co-op and we are happy to
announce that PvP will be available at
launch for all players but that's not
all you'll achieve the same character
throughout your whole experience in
breakpoint this means you keep the same
customization the same skills the same
weapons the same progression across the
entire game and this is just the
beginning every four months after launch
we'll release a new major expansion
episode to the game that'll include the
very first raid in a Ghost Recon game
here's a taste of what's to come
a lot of people put tons of passion into
the making of this game we could not
have done it without you
our community and so it is our pleasure
to present to you our world premiere our
announce trailer for Ghost Recon
breakpoint
[Music]
I am a ghost
Annelise soldier
to strike my enemies before they know I
exist
talk to me
I survived
overcoming any obstacle
[Music]
never surrender him
and with my brothers and sisters at my
side
there is no fight we fear
[Applause]
you're afraid of death
so would you take the life of my
brothers
[Music]
me
doesn't matter how
I will
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a ghost do I would expect nothing
less
[Music]
Ghost Recon breakpoint is here it's a
strap on your boots because you have a
mission stay tuned to hear more live
from our studio we'll be there to answer
your questions
you
Oh catch our breath after that reveal we
are here at GameSpot live and we are
brought to you by Ubisoft
my name is Persia and I am here with
Jack Pattillo hello hi Internet how are
you guys doing today well we've been
watching that reveal right alongside you
guys and I am like yeah oh yeah that was
it's one of the things worse like you
see a game where it's like okay like I
loved wildlands and I love kind of how
they built up this world and now it's
like let's take it to the next step
let's take it to the next level and oh
my gosh everything we saw in there and
they reveal right there at the end yeah
okay okay we've got a lot of stuff to
talk about over the next a bit of time
right yes like a ton to go over and a
time to just highlight in general like
right from the start they made it very
clear like they wanted us to really step
in the shoes of these soldiers and you
know experience what they experienced
all the time in such a realistic way on
top of that which I think they're
capturing pretty well so far yeah I
think it's gonna be tough for me to
really find myself in the form of a big
white dude with a beard it's gonna be is
gonna be a lot of trouble where I'm like
I don't know how he react like would he
clean his beard would he get the mud out
of it would he keep going through no
it's it this looks awesome and obviously
like I mean they get yeah I mean we're
just processing we literally just
finished watching they're watching all
this with you guys first time I've seen
any of this stuff and I'm very very
excited for it it looks awesome we've
got so much stuff to talk about freaking
because you're just talking about how
much you love the raids and they're
bringing it to Ghost Recon for the first
time ever first time yeah it looked
awesome too like the crazy locations of
all Caine it's funny they mentioned a
volcano early on and I'm like that that
volcano I want to explore that and it
looks like the raid might be involving a
volcano stuff but anyway how should we
start where should we start from the
beginning even started because there was
so much like even right from the
beginning they talked about a Rolla
right
if you guys played through operation
Oracle which now makes a lot more sense
to us because this storyline kind of
feels like a direct extension of that we
get to see more of Walker but if you
remember last time we left off he kind
of trusted us a little bit something
serious went down a row up beautiful it
covers all these different types of
terrain and the volcanoes so they
definitely stress that this terrain is
gonna play a big impact in our you know
every big game play every minute yeah I
mean it's it seems like any time some
rich you know smart dude gets an island
nothing good comes to that nothing
nothing good ever comes out we had Jace
Kell who's the the guy who's designing
these robots it's always like oh yeah
robots gonna be good and then you strap
a gun to it and then everything changes
I don't know why then we got it we got
so we're gonna tell you on must know
guns on any on any Tesla's cuz yeah
that's where it all goes downhill but
exactly and you know they kind of nailed
it on the head in the preview is that
okay yeah you mean while this technology
is gonna be great but in the wrong hands
not so great then we get introduced to
the Wolves right yeah which clearly is
Walker squad yeah they look badass too
look at that look at those shells like
who gets to pick that like why don't one
of the good guys wear stuff like that
good guys are always like you know we'll
put a little like makeup under our eyes
and look pretty cool but I'm a theater
while I'm walking around killing people
like come on man that's that we to be
fair the amount of customization it
looks like it's going to happen in this
game I'm sure we're gonna end up gettin
stuff like that like they bought like
the the ghost game has always been
really good about really making your
character what you want to make it and
I'm sure we'll see some cool modifier
stuff so and they definitely stress the
fact that they've been listening to the
community and you know customisation
options are one of the many things they
are bringing to the game to you know
make this a better experience for
everyone playing at home yeah I always
love I love that about you be soft
titles like I'm self-professed Ubisoft
fanboy a hundred percent and I love that
they always seem to win one
game figures it out you see other
Ubisoft titles pick up that stuff and
then take it in stare game like even
like the gunsmith here you're like in
Division two right now like there's a
lot of customization here for weapons I
imagine a lot of the stuff is like hey
we figured this out over here why don't
we help you over here and like even
something simple like picking up a body
and carrying officer yeah oh my god like
that's an assassin's Creed thing like
absolutely you can pick up a body and
hide it or like and now you know pick up
a wounded soldier carry them somewhere
else be able to give them heals
elsewhere instead of in the line of fire
I love I love that Ubisoft been very
open and very like you know let's take
what we've done in other games and
implement it into our newer ones and
they've done a really really fantastic
job of that and I'm excited to see what
other elements of other games we're
going to see in this yes but before we
even like get to that something that
really stuck out to me was the wound
oh my god you get shy get wounded you
just hide for a little bit everything
goes back to normal then on about your
date not so much they're gonna make you
think twice about going out there
Rambo status like trying to run and gun
because these this damage is gonna take
its toll over time and you have to heal
yours but don't you know like once you
get shot in the leg you just you know
give yourself a good 15 seconds and
you're fine that's how it is shake it
off you know rub some mud in there
you're fine no it's um it's pretty I
mean I dork it is I love seeing this
dude wrapping bandages around his arm
you know like it's something about like
okay you always see like just put
something on when you're done it's like
to actually see like oh there's a
physical bandage on his arm and it's
like no you're just wrapping the same
thing every time and that's just the cue
that you're healing yourself but he went
for the arm that damage went for the leg
that was damaged in those details really
make it an immersive experience yeah
it's it's it's it's one of those things
that I know is gonna be annoying as hell
and you're playing the games like oh god
come on not the arm again you know and
they even mentioned like later on if you
get injured it might affect your aiming
like you might not be able to carry a
heavy weapon based on you know how hurt
you are and so that to me is pretty nuts
and then hiding and like simple stuff
like even when he's in the water right
here he's carrying his gun above the
water he keeps it lifted up and it's
like oh that's such
simple thing that you don't really think
about but someone had to program that
like he never lets his a his weapons hit
the actual water like that's so cool and
the way he like runs and slowly he
started something muscling the way
through and then we get our predator
moment here in bit where he gets off
covering mud like that on the deer of
course that series dead that deers dead
as hell by the way yeah like that the
act of camo it was like that was that
was amazing prone camo yeah and so the
dislike covers himself in mud like
that's I slay yeah something you
probably do in real life well I wanted
cuz I hate getting money but I mean I it
means like it's so caught me it's it's
so nice though because these are the
moments that are like the most
terrifying when you look up and you're
surrounded by enemies but he's like okay
I'm just gonna lay here and now I'm
gonna roll around in the mud be myself
dirty what she's exciting but then I
just know I'd be gross from that point
on so I would it gets all in the beer
gets in the beer you're dead that's true
that's true and I will say here I'd like
we were watching this earlier so he goes
prone very sneaky very stealthy and then
of course he looks around he's got guys
surrounding him everywhere he stealth
kills one guy and then goes loud which
is exactly my technique in any game like
this I can I get one or two stealth
kills and then all hell breaks loose
it's like alright running gun here we go
start shooting but uh yeah yeah so here
he goes covered in mud that's not good
you know he's got open wounds too
I know and he goes for the prison's dab
where he gets the multiple stabs as well
yeah and then at this point so this is
where they revealed like oh here we go
this isn't just the solo experience
because now we're bringing in we're
bringing in your buddies here and so
they didn't explicitly say it but
clearly there's some kind of class
system here because this dude's more of
your salt kind of traditional basic one
we saw a sniper we saw a heavy weapons
guy we saw it looks the smokes are you
so maybe is some kind of support class
and wild answers are really good about
that where you could kind of create your
character how you want how you like to
play
personally I'm always the support guy I
like I like sitting back marking enemies
I like you know helping people out
healing people and it looks like there's
a hundred percent gonna be available in
this as well which it makes me very
excited I'm sure expanded upon as well
yeah I mean they mention that for
classes we're gonna be available at
lunch with more to come so that's always
something they look forward to I'm
actually very excited they are keeping
like with tradition you know that same
support we're always used to is gonna
continue to happen and you know in this
day and age that's something very very
important you know for any community and
their game is to have that constant
support yeah yeah it's like we get this
major reveal all these trailers all this
hype and then guess what there's still
more on the way yeah absolutely
and one thing one thing really cool too
is the progression so the progression
carries through the entire game which is
important because you know as you play
these characters you can start leveling
up getting different weapons and
especially although the modifications do
with the gunsmith having that be able to
carry across everything is gonna be
great and I'm curious about PvP as well
because it's launching with PvP which is
neat because I remember wildlands took
some time for the PvP hit and that was a
really really neat style of PvP so I'm
curious I want to learn more about that
because I like freak to kind of pick the
classes and sort of play like that and
I'm curious if it's more gonna be the
character you make in single-player will
be the same character you bring into PvP
and if that progression carries over
that would be pretty intense too but hey
they did say shared progression that
would make sense I think so yes so in
meaning you can really kind of like iron
out the kind of character you want to
play but to be fair playing PvE versus
PvP is a radically different experience
so you know it's gonna be interesting
but also it looks like the was the bio
that was called bivouac yeah this is
biblic so you can customize your
character so if there is a class you
want to play that you know you could
just swap in like classes like that like
that's pretty cool and you can modify
and customize your character constantly
so and you know that's really similar to
like what real soldiers use out in the
field and stuff like that so I
definitely get this realism vibe like
that's something they're definitely
going for and I think it's working
really well because it makes me
interested it's making me think a little
bit harder about my corrosive action and
what I'm gonna do next and you know
actually forcing me to prepare instead
of just oh here's my objective and I'm
gonna go him so yeah I like that I like
that it's involving a little bit of prep
time because there are cool new
additions like the breach system yeah
that I was like man I wish I could just
open this gate right now I'm like that I
can yeah I wrote that down I was like
finally we can reach a fence because
nothing was more frustrating than it's
like okay I need to get right on the
other side of this wall here I'm ten
feet away but I'm gonna go all the way
around or somehow get up and that's just
like oh we don't have just a wire cutter
you know it's like here we go we finally
we can actually breach offense as simple
as it seems it's like oh that's that's
awesome and I love to that'll like you
can see it like we're track because the
heat is a cool there we go and I like
that it's not just a bolt cutter it's
like a torch oh yeah no we're
technologically-advanced this is this is
a really lovely location to like if if
there wasn't a horrible war and people
dying I would love to visit this place
and I do like this sort of juxtaposition
of like you know the the jungle and all
the chaos and there's these really nice
modern looking IKEA houses you know
after all like this is the scale tech HQ
you know they got all the tech in there
and of course the drones are back which
I loved I loved the drone so much in my
lens and that's actually gonna be what
helps you with the same shot and
everything like that when you're playing
alone because I think you're only really
gonna add those teammates when you're
playing the co-op mode and then the
drones are kind of like your support
system when you're your soul yeah they
mentioned that specifically that the
drones can do the sync shots which is
one of my favorite things to do is like
something about marking for people and I
say all right countdown three two one
fire and then it's a watching all these
bodies at the floor is so great and so
Brayton the idea you can do that by
yourself now it's like pretty cool so
you don't have to play with other people
or someone who just keeps ruining it for
you probably make it easier to acquire
those sing shots too because that was
always something too sometimes I would
be so far ahead of my teammates and I
would have to wait for them to catch up
to acquire the shot and stuff like that
so I think it's gonna be really
interesting definitely gonna help kind
of tailor the the missions that you're
using to fit your style better than you
and you're like AI teammates around yeah
yeah yeah and also so they added some
new technology including including
sliding down a mountain technology which
we we finally get in so many games it's
pretty much just like just run straight
down a mountain it's like nope nope
you're sliding yeah
putting and go so he and he was like
rolling and I was like yeah that sounds
exactly how it would happen with me yeah
yeah and so of course you got your your
tactical baseball hat as well like I
love I love the hats and like the bucket
had the dudes wearing their and like I
yeah that's their own prone takedown
which is super super dorky but I love it
like the leg grab and snap they're so
aggressive with the knives in this game
yeah my god they're vicious
you're like a happy stealth kill you
know it's like they don't know they're
gonna die but it's like no no they're
they're very much like yeah we're gonna
know what's coming we're gonna really do
about it man something about flying
death machines is just terrifying
like like AI death machines at any
capacity there's just just really really
scary but I do love that you know we
went inside this building eventually and
you saw the civilians as well which is
kind of like oh there's just their
cities out there that's like oh we're
not gonna actually hunt those people and
like I'm curious as to what like what
were to happen if one of them does like
take collateral damage like does this
all hell break loose
or is it like you want to not you know
take out people or innocence even though
they probably made all the death robots
so that's there's so many civilians are
you to me to your own people because it
is gonna affect you at some point theme
so I would have seen was definitely
gonna be up that alley and also you know
we're not asking the civilians here to
make this island a better place and to
hopefully not get hunted by these wolves
and like on top of all of that the
wolves in the comments and everything I
noticed like some more intense combat
system in the preview of the mission oh
yeah where it was like he was running up
to him and like going for you know
mainly like what we're used to but it
actually looked a little bit more like a
combat system yeah something of the sort
more animations definitely cool yeah
there was definitely like like I think
she ran up to the guy and then it was a
back-and-forth it wasn't just like I'm
gonna hit a button go through a cutscene
and we're done it's like oh there may
actually be some sort of like fight
there we
we'll have to find out more in the
future it's crazy that I mean there been
two decades now of Ghost Recon and just
to think of words gone from like
Advanced Warfighter all the way up to
wild lands it's a breakpoint now it's
it's nuts like how much is changing how
it's just it's a fun game it's a really
really cool game though the way they
sort of adapted and changed over the
years has been really neat and I've
loved the franchise earlier you
mentioned that you play it like every
year that's cool so you probably have
the best opinion of most people like how
do you feel about their evolution of
their games with the announcement of
break point I think it's been fantastic
like they've they've definitely kind of
taken on the whole idea of adding more
people and making it more of a social
thing like from division 2 we're like
now I mean you know we've really opened
up it's like division 2 is the best when
you're playing with other people
same thing with wildlands like when
you're playing wild lands with three
friends and like that's a blast and it's
like driving around together goofing
around even like the Far Cry titles like
playing co-op and Far Cry it's like
something about but playing with a buddy
is so much fun and they've been very
good about showing that off in their
different titles like every time you see
a promo every time you see a new new
game for some of our new release for
something they always show the
multiplayer stuff and so I think that
that's one of the big focuses and I
think that's they've done a really
really good job of that and the idea of
raids coming to ghoshal uconn now like I
know the raid in in Division two is
gonna be eight players I'm curious what
its gonna be in this one so I don't if
they could expand that past you know
from four out to eight or or maybe even
further than that who knows and how does
that work what is the story behind it
like word all these people all these
girls coming together to fight like the
raid boss or whatever it's gonna be
which looks like a flying tank maybe and
in a volcano is yeah it looks ridiculous
but it's like the progression like UV
stuff's been really really good about
about taking these worlds and expanding
upon them and not not just kind of
wiping them out and start over fresh
like this is this is a universe that
exists within the Ghost Recon world and
it makes sense like oh yeah obviously
this is where I would go like this could
all tie together somehow and so I'm
still waiting for the ultimate you know
Ubisoft is a cinematic universe you know
where it turns out all of these games
are all together but then we get stuff
like this like you think maybe like the
skeleton would have shown up in
watchdogs or maybe it isn't washed
under a different name I yeah I have a
lot of conspiracy theories about maybe
maybe Skell Tech is part of Abstergo who
also works with far anyway and we've
learned at least today is that they're
listening and they care about what you
think so like that definitely shows and
combat system and like he's mentioned
the raids before like Mike before maybe
eight well you know you guys can always
let them know I love the more the
merrier man so something about but the
raids in particular for pretty much any
title like something about working
together cooperatively to achieve a
common goal is so much fun like that
that's some of my favorite constant ever
is doing rate rate fights and various
games and so I'm really pumped for the
raid to come out in in Division two
whenever that hit that's I know that's
coming out soon yeah and like the idea
of raising this is like okay okay I want
to I want to do this now too and so in
it's just yeah the idea of being able
develop a character make your character
exactly what you want to do taking those
skills and bring it into a game is so
much fun and then and then my big thing
is again as a support class I like
helping other people do better so it's
like hey maybe you can like play an
assault character or like a heavy
character and I'm gonna keep you alive
so you just go tank and I'm just gonna
keep you healed up and alive it looks
like they do have more tailored classes
yeah it was like that definitely seems
like they're promoting people to assign
themselves these roles within your
squads who provide the best possible
course of action because they want you
to prepare for these missions you're
also fighting against former ghosts - or
at least walkers my frickin Locker yeah
that's that was kind of I mean yeah that
were okay where we got we have a pretty
sweet antagonist that looks like yeah I
mean he's not he's not a happy looking
dude even in the operation Oracle teaser
you know he says all of two lines but
those two lines actually told me a lot
right he's like you know at some point
even a ghost needs help right and then
you look forward to this like yeah
you're right these guys like you they
need some help right now they're being
hunted and so on and so forth but then
he's also you know ends it with seeing
but lucky for you or good for you imma
go
now they have to fight against him and
take him down with him having access to
this technology like how do you think
that's even gonna set the tone for the
difficulty of this game no kidding man
yeah I mean like the idea that a ghost
with all this sort of evil tech and all
these drones and stuff like that's nuts
to me but that's it goes on to show you
again like how cool it is that Ubisoft
like has this sort of world where it's
like in wildlands we're gonna tease the
next game like it literally will lead
into the next game via DLC it's like
that's that's awesome or an expansion
it's like that's so cool that they're
able to like drop this one little story
and it's like oh here's a little mission
that's totally setting up the next game
like that is really really even have
like likes likes like Sam Fisher showed
up to a 1-point wildlands and it's like
cool all right like all these worlds are
all connected and like this just one
constant flow of narrative and I love
that they're able to do that and able to
pull this stuff off and again seeing
seeing a barren thought looking down a
music that's pretty frightening man and
no you don't want to get on his bad side
I don't think and soundly and you know
he said it even in the end of the
trailer it's like there's nothing I
won't do if someone you know crosses me
or my brothers and sisters and obviously
from the end of Oracle we know that
Walker is walking that line no pun
intended you know feeling burned by
losing his squad and you know his gut
brothers and sisters and now like he's
like no more I'm not gonna let it happen
like he's like I'm taking over now yeah
he's got some scars man he's been he
seems to be some rough times there
that's pretty intense I gotta say to
shout out to the devs i love what i love
watching Dems and they were all being
very badass and just kind of sitting
like yeah I love that kind of stuff oh I
love that Ubisoft is doing stuff like
that where they're kind of highlighting
like these the people who make the game
it's because so so often I mean
literally they mentioned there are
thousands of people working on the Ghost
Recon games and it's like it's cool to
see them kind of like giving shout out
to those people cuz like you know they
make it they make this everything that
it is and like having them up front
having the community person up there as
well it's like seeing her out there is
like oh yeah there they are talking the
community and say we want to make it a
point to show like this is a person
behind it here's the face behind the
community
team and Ubisoft that's that's so cool
yeah I think it's great like so many
people put their time and effort into
these games that we have the honor of
playing so it's it is nice to put a face
to those people and I mean from what
you've seen so far like with all the
reveals and all the trailers so far what
do you think is the most game-changing
thing they look forward to man I don't I
don't know like there's so many things I
just really want to get in and
experience the story I mean that's
that's always my thing it's kind of like
how did this happen how did Walker turn
and like that's and like the narrative
stuff for me and that's always my big
thing like like I enjoy PvP I'm not that
great at PvP so I usually stick to the
PvE side of things and that's usually
when you get you nice narratives your
story and the idea of like I mean having
having a rich genius evil guys always
lots of fun having like this tropical
lush island like okay that's gonna be a
lot of fun but I want to figure out
what's going on why did why did Walker
turn like he seems like he was and so
the idea that like he was I mean he was
a ghost and like what made him go like
oh yeah I don't I'm on the wrong side of
this like what made him think that like
oh I should be on the side of the evil
death robots that's what I should be
that's true because you know even in
Oracle there was a point where he was
like yeah well at least I know what side
I'm on now I think that was less of
ghosts and wolves now and more right and
wrong you know he wants to be on the
right side he thinks that the way you
know everything was handled before and
how he lost his men was the wrong way so
you get this moral like compromise now
right like he doesn't think he was wrong
we think he's wrong I if it is directly
related to Oracle and the fact that he
lost his man and somewhere in between we
find out that Kieran might have been on
the wrong side of some sort which pushed
him over the edge
it may be past his break point you could
say
I mean really I mean honestly too just
like watching the trailers and like
watching the gameplay the amount of
different kind of landscapes is that's
what I want to get into it's like seeing
the snowy mountain it's like I want to
take some of these vehicles down you
know it wasn't the Fat Boy like tear
through the germinal and the Fat Boy and
it's like that's gonna be lots of fun
and this is you know even just riding
around with like three buddies in a
vehicle like this just like cruising
around just jumping over stuff that's
always a blast and like just exploring a
new world and those are terrifying
looking vehicles right there if they
have no driver there's death machines
with guns and then they use their own
vehicle this is one of the things like
in the game you'd be like oh yeah
totally meant to do that yeah yeah
totally going to jump out and use my
vehicle as a battering ram and then blow
it up yep
meant to do that yeah totally totally
crushed but yeah then flying around I'm
hopefully we need helicopters and fly
around the island - you like that
objective looks a little too far time to
steal a helicopter yeah like they just
showed us so many and different features
new things obviously more awesome things
are on the way they already announced
every four months a new expansion coming
to the game that is already something to
look forward to and the game isn't even
out yet it's coming out October 4
October 4th man yeah it's it looks good
even like did right this starting I'm
just looking over my notes like going
back to the start it felt very intense
like it felt like you I mean it the idea
is you're being hunted and that opening
sequence there it was like oh Jesus like
that guy was running he was not fighting
back he was just trying to hide and stay
alive yeah and also one thing - if
you've ever played a Ubisoft shooter
title you know to avoid helicopters like
the plague it seems like no one has a
good time in the helicopters to start
the games like five helicopters don't
seem to survive very long when you're
going for narrative structure in a give
you soft title especially over an island
so stay away from the helicopters but
yeah like right here the beginning it's
just like he was running around and it's
just like just keep moving like get away
and that's yeah this is terrifying like
everything's all blurry and he's panting
and breathing and spitting out blood
like that's that's a fun way to start
off a game again yeah poor guy and you
can see that he can't even pick up the
gun all the way yeah like he's living in
it looks like you might not be able to
eating down sight because his left arm
is injured so yeah something gonna add
an extreme element to the gameplay of
this game honestly I feel like this
might be one of the most difficult go
three con games with all these other
elements it being very realistic and
obviously it's gonna be drawing your
attention to so many different things
and with the main thing being survival I
think it's gonna be really difficult
what I'm looking forward to that you
know I feel like a lot of games nowadays
they don't want to challenge you as hard
but this looks like a challenge that I'm
looking forward to well I've got a
feeling you're gonna start I mean you
always start it's kind of like rags to
riches right so like you start off super
rough very clearly close to death and
then by the end of it you're gonna feel
like a super soldier even by the end of
it I have a feeling going up against
Walker is gonna be like okay I don't
think I'm ready you know no matter what
so yeah I'm pumped I'm pumped to see the
progression of it though and see like
what you encounter and like can you use
any of those drones for you maybe like
you turn them against their owners
exactly some watchdog stuff and it'll be
great so I'm really seeing not only the
game come out but seeing how they expand
you know each chapter with the new
updates and kind of evolves this story
I'm super interested to learn more about
the story itself like you mentioned
before like so many things could have
happened right we don't really know we
can make the assumptions but we won't
really know until the game comes out so
be sure to keep your eyes peeled get
your hands on those pre-orders October 4
October 4 so far away now that I've seen
all this she's that's erisa more this is
just like five months out I mean that's
it it's crazy like I love that I love
the idea to that it's like oh here's an
announcement oh by the way it's coming
very very soon you know well it's like
before it'd be like alright this will be
out in two or three years no no here we
go it's coming out that's coming out
soon you're getting it you're gonna be
enjoying this this fall so I'm amped for
it I know about you but I'm ready for it
I am definitely looking forward to it I
mean just off the top of my head some of
my favorite changes they've made is that
when the Buddy Cary system
because that was something you know even
playing wildlands I would be all
stealthy and snipe someone but guess
what they found their buddy and now they
suspect me oh yeah I mean it got to a
point where I would try to like grab
them and then drag them off but I like
this a lot better it's really cool well
that's great and also like in me like me
I try to keep people alive so there's
like you run out in the middle of a
bunch of firefight and it's like well
you're dead in front of everyone like I
could run out grab you and hopefully get
you away from them like that's cool
like that's something new and it makes
total sense and like even in that we saw
her throw the smoke screen down and then
run and grab the guy and drop them off
and work on him it's like oh yeah okay
good like that's 100% that kind of stuff
I'll be pulling off so that seems
realistic anything you'd like to also
talk about in high light I feel like I
made all these notes and we've nailed
them all on the hell yeah yeah how does
hat stay on that's that's what I'm
curious about again I got the guy had a
bucket hat on and he was getting thrown
around shot at what sort of hat
technology did Skell come up with that
hats don't leave heads that's it's
unfair yeah yeah also that crazy helmet
was like the camera on the front too
like what is that I don't see that in
real life I want to walk around with a
helmet head in a camera and see if that
makes me any more of a badass I probably
actually the other really eerie thing
about this storyline is that yeah it's
you know skill tech you know technical
technologically advanced robots but none
of these inventions actually feel like
they're that far out of reach like right
now yeah yeah I think those drones if
you took those guns off the drones you
can see those Disneyworld right now like
in the light shows and stuff like that's
what it is but you know then you slap
some weapons on and we got ourselves a
Ghost Recon game so I think that's
that's the issue right there so yeah I
just don't don't put bullets and weapons
on on drones please don't don't let AI
have weapons yet not yet well I just
think not really this game but I did
watch this they did develop a robot that
can fire again and I was like that is
terrifying
and then now I'm watching the trailer
I'm like it's really not that impossible
for something like that
yeah I think that adds to the effect
that this game is actually just gonna
have on us period oh yeah like you even
saw that like it starts like in 2019 and
was like the first like robot had killed
somebody and then it's like just a few
years later it's like okay I mean when
you know when your Roomba has a pistol
on it you know we're in trouble so it's
for home protection and also vacuums
your floor's yeah once that starts
happening then we're we're gonna have
some we're gonna have to have some
discussions I think on a higher level
but I agree but with all that said
everybody we hope you enjoyed the reveal
stream we hope you enjoyed our post show
that was brought to you by Ubisoft and
Jack it was just awesome chatting with
you yeah this game man I just gotta I
gotta start prepping myself for October
4th and keep an eye on your Roombas
because they're out there coming after
you is what's gonna happen hopefully not
hopefully not hopefully you'll be fine
yes you'll be if anything I'll teach us
to pick up a broom and kick it you guys
keep your eyes peeled October 4th Ghost
Recon break point is gonna be in your
hands so hope you're looking forward to
it as much as we are and we hope you
enjoyed the show but until next time
we'll see you guys later
you